ce qu'on a vu pendant la pandémie c'est
que quand on enlève le tourisme la ville
s'arrête parce qu'effectivement le
tourisme c'est le cœur du lien social de
la société moderne on n'est plus dans
des sociétés où les gens habitent à un
endroit tout le temps puisqu'à Paris par
exemple le nombre de nuitée où les
Parisiens ne dorment pas dans la ville
et le même que le nombre de nuits des
touristes dans la ville c'est à dire que
les touristes viennent beaucoup à Paris
évidemment mais en réalité vu que le
nombre de la nuitée ou les Parisiens
sont pas dans leur ville parce qu'ils
sont en vacances ils sont en weekend etc
en fait le total est égal à zéro pas en
chiffre d'affaires les touristes
dépensent plus que l'habitant parisien
tous les jours mais en nombre de nuité
c'est pour donner les masses si vous
voulez qui sont absolument considérables
bien donc on est dans ce dans ce
mouvement de fond et je crois qu'il faut
se poser des questions d'abord si vous
en se disant quel est notre objectif
culturel et politique je crois qu'il
faut dire que il faut continuer à
développer le voyage développer le
tourisme développer la découverte de
l'autre c'est ce qui peut nous permettre
de faire une mondialisation pas trop
guerrière pour le dire comme ça
je pense si vous voulez que le voyage on
va pas revenir à Montaigne etc c'est un
élément central de phénomène de paix
social et de paix politique je dirais
aussi que l'absence de voyage pendant
deux ans à mon avis accentué les
conflits que ça soit dans les couples
avec un million de séparation mais même
les conflits militaires les sociétés se
sont repliées sur elles-mêmes les gens
se sont repliés sur le local et donc
effectivement on montait renforcé les
nationalismes etc donc il y a un rapport
entre tous ces phénomènes
ça c'est la toile de fond donc notre
objectif il me semble qu'on doit la
finir c'est que le voyage doit se
développer moi je vous donnerai deux
objectifs chiffrés je dirais il faut 80
% des Français qui partent en vacances
comme objectif de 2050 il faut
demi-heure et demi touristes
internationaux c'est-à-dire je poserai
d'abord l'objectif en termes culturel en
termes sociales évidemment avec les
conséquences économiques qu'on peut voir